the judge in the written house case bars
msnbc from the courtroom after a porter
allegedly follows jurors democrats in
the house make yet another push for
buildback better and the ground swell
begins for an aoc presidential run god
help us all i'm bench pro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first black friday is when
you start saving money right well why
don't you start saving money now like
why wait until black friday you could be
saving a ton of money by switching your
cell phone coverage provider okay you're
spending way too much money for that
right now because you want those great
5g towers right well what if you get the
exact same coverage at like half the
price this is where puretalk comes in
pure talk will give you killer 5g
coverage on one of the largest 5g
networks in the country and still save
the average family over 800 a year i
made the switch the coverage is
excellent their us-based customer
service actually cares about you and
pure tax prices are pretty much
wholesale unlimited talk tax six gigs of
data for just 30 a month keep your
number keep your phone or this month and
get black friday prices on new phones
like the iphone 12 for just 479 bucks
it's a big savings we've got a 30 day
risk free guarantee so you literally
have nothing to lose go to puretalk.com
shop for the plan and phone that's right
for you and then enter promo code
shapiro and you will save 50 off your
very first month and save on a new phone
at the same time that is puretalk.com
promo code shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless some restrictions apply
see site for details alrighty so another
crazy development in the written house
trial now remember the jury is still out
at this point we don't know what is
going on with the jury the speculation
seems to me that a hung jury is coming
andrew mccarthy writing for national
review he says that he believes that a
hung jury is likely is it midday on
thursday as the third day of
deliberations dragged on and there grew
a foreboding sense that the jury may be
deadlocked over a very straightforward
case the judge announced he had banned
msnbc from the courtroom
the the judge of course is bruce
schrader schroeder elaborated that on
wednesday evening a man who identified
himself as affiliated with msnbc a guy
named james morrison was stopped by
police as he tracked the jury at close
range running a red light in that
pursuit the jurors were in a large
vehicle with covered windows from which
they had been escorted to and from court
schrader said that morrison claimed to
have been acting under the direction of
an msnbc producer in new york
now we all know that msnbc has been
blatantly anti-written house with all of
its hosts attacking written house
suggesting that he's guilty suggesting
he's a racist and a white supremacist
and that the outcome of this trial
is going to speak for the future of race
relations in america despite the fact
that only three white people got shot
here was uh here is the judge announcing
that he had barred msnbc from the
courtroom after this
i have instructed that no one from msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
this is a very serious matter and i
don't know what the ultimate truth of it
is
but absolutely it would go without
much
thinking
that someone who is following as
the jury bus
that is a very ex that's extremely
serious matter
and will be referred to the
proper authorities obviously that is
insanity you got reporters following
jurors apparently
some of these reporters claim that they
do this thing to get the license plate
numbers of the jurors and they do this
fairly regularly apparently and notice
they can ask the jurors about what they
were thinking after the case is over
that's insane it's especially insane
given the high profile nature of the
trial and the fact that many of these
jurors all of them live in kenosha which
means that they are subject to the
problems that are going to arise in
kenosha if they come down the wrong way
according to an msnbc spokesperson they
said last night a freelancer received a
traffic citation while the traffic
violation took place near the jury van
the freelancer never contacted or
intended to contact the jurors during
deliberations and never photographed or
intended to photograph them we regret
the incident and will fully cooperate
with the authorities on any
investigation
now as andy mccarthy
suggests he says
i said i think a quick verdict would
have favored written house if
deliberations instead drag out there's a
greater chance of a hung jury or a
compromise verdict in this case
any mccarthy says in a compromised
verdict former prosecutor which can be
scandalous but is nevertheless
permissible in our system jurors avoid a
hopeless deadlock by agreeing to convict
the accused on some but not other
charges or on lesser charges that is
neither of those who believe the
defendant should be acquitted nor those
who want him convicted on severe charges
get what they want but a verdict is
reached even if it is not rational
i.e it's not internally consistent or
aligned with the proof a compromised
verdict sounds like a tie in the sense
the defendant neither walks nor faces
life imprisonment in reality it's a
victory for the state because
rittenhouse would stand convicted of a
felony and face significant prison time
what is a quick verdict says andy
mccarthy depends on the case i was a
junior prosecutor in the longest federal
criminal trial in american history the
pizza connection case 1985-87 the jury
was out for six days for the written
house case that would seem like an
eternity but in our case after 17 months
of trying a raft of charges against 22
defendants it seems extraordinarily
quick
as i write this piece we are seven hours
into the third day of deliberations in
the written house trial that already
seems long especially because the trial
was less than two weeks of testimony and
the question is whether the defendant
acted in justifiable self-defense or
even whether there is reasonable doubt
that he did so remember the standard
isn't did he act in self-defense is is
there reasonable doubt that he might
have done so right that's the defense
and that's the standard
is there reasonable doubt is the
clearest cascade i mean it's a clear-cut
case of self-defense it is in 197
clear-cut case that there is reasonable
doubt as to whether he
engaged in self-defense
what this does suggest is that there may
be a situation in which
the judge simply declares a mistrial if
the jury comes back
deadlocked maybe a mistrial with
prejudice he just says we're not doing
this again there have certainly been
enough cases of of
mistrial laden behavior by the
prosecution to support that
if the jury comes back and acquits the
judge is off the hook if the jury comes
back and and says hung jury the judge
could theoretically declare a mistrial
they would have the same impact as a
hung jury unless he did so with
prejudice which means that they can't
refile the case if they come back guilty
he could still declare a mistrial or
mistrial with prejudice based on what is
going on so there's a long way to go in
this trial even once the jury comes back
and uh and andy mccarthy is fairly
critical about traitor the judge he says
i'm i'm constrained to observe one's
assessment of judge bruce schrader does
not improve with extended observation in
the latest gripe session schrader
bleeded about how how he'd been handled
for how he'd been criticized for his
handling of defense motion from this
trial he said he had not even had a
chance to read since it had only been
filed the previous day
but the motion is six pages long double
double spaced
he says it appears that trader made up
his mind before the trial there would be
no sequestration and he is muellishly
sticking to that but that was a mistake
because now that they've not been
sequestered the jury they can be easily
intimidated and it appears that that is
at the very least a possibility given
the fact that msnbc is now apparently
sending reporters as stringers to follow
members of the jury
so that is uh that is bad stuff
alrighty in one second we'll get to the
chaos that has now broken out on the
left side of the aisle everybody knows
joe biden is not running for reelection
at this point because he cannot even
walk it is very difficult to run for
reelection when you cannot walk okay
we'll get to more of that in just a
second first i got to tell you every
time my wife and i go for a long car
ride she gets nauseous or at least she
used to get nauseous because of the car
sickness until she started using relief
band relief band is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband it's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy provides
all-natural long-lasting relief zero
side effects for as long as needed it
really is like a really it's a cool
piece of technology it was originally
developed over 20 years ago in hospitals
to relieve nausea from patients now
relief band is available to the masses
relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist it travels to the part of the
brain that controls nausea then it
blocks the signal your brain is sending
to your stomach telling you that you're
sick and now relief band has released
its newest model relief band sports the
sport is waterproof features
interchangeable bands and has extended
battery life as well i got one for my
sister because my sister was having some
morning sickness and relief man helped
her out it can help you out as well as
the holiday season quickly approaches
there's never been a better time to give
the gift of relief make sure your loved
ones are nausea free right now relief
ban is running their biggest sale of the
year if you head to reliefband.com
you'll receive 25 off all orders you
don't even need a promo code don't miss
out on this deal that's
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d-d.com receive 25 off
all orders through november 28th
alrighty so
one thing has become eminently clear on
the left side of the aisle and that is
that they are panicked about 2024. the
reason they're panicked about 2024 is
because
joe biden made the idiotic decision to
pick as his vice president not somebody
who was a plausible 2024 candidate but
somebody who had completely flamed out
as an early candidate in 2020 kamal
harris who didn't even last through the
california primary she didn't even get
to her home state despite being the
early leader
in the presidential race
she she had all of the benefits of
intersectionality she was a senator from
california
she had shellacked joe biden in the
first debate by suggesting that he was a
racist and then later in the race
suggested that he was a sexual assaulter
and then she dropped out of the race
because she's terrible at everything
because all she has done for her entire
career is fail up democrats are so
disquieted with her that cnn reported
the other day they were talking about
elevating her to the supreme court just
to get her out of the way
that would be the greatest case of
failing upward in american history you
go from being a crappy ag to being a
crappy senator to being a crappy vice
president to being a crappy supreme
court justice
really america is the land of
opportunity
okay well kamala harris did yet another
national interview yesterday and they
just they all go badly for her she's
with george stephanopoulos i will never
ever ever get over the fact that george
stephanopoulos is presented as a news
person i will never get over it as an
objective news person
this guy was an advisor to hillary and
bill clinton again uh
if karl rove were presented as an
objective news reporter that is the
equivalent of making george
stephanopoulos an objective news source
the media bias is so ripe but here's the
thing kamal harris can't even sound good
when speaking with george stephanopoulos
whose job it is to carry around a drool
cup for her
it's insane so here is kamala harris
explaining that you can't fix the border
eight months ago the president gave you
the job of addressing the root causes of
migration but last month we learned that
in the past year had the highest number
of illegal border courses since they
started to be recorded in 1960 what are
you doing to turn that around how long
will it take
well it's not going to be overnight we
can't just flip a switch and make it
better
the reality is that we inherit a system
an immigration system that was deeply
broken
and it's requiring us to actually put it
back together in terms of creating a
fair
process that is effective and efficient
okay um yeah we can't fix it is a really
not a good answer considering this was
delegated to you this was your job
the joe biden sent you down not to the
border to the to the
latin american central american triangle
to try and solve this thing you've done
nothing and then you said that you had
visited the border when you had not
visited the border and then you said you
don't understand why you should visit
the border
and
you're almost laughing we can tell
you're almost laughing the nervous
bizarre cackle that breaks out every
time kamala harris has asked a question
she's almost there with every one of
these questions and these are not super
tough questions okay george
stephanopoulos then asked her a softball
does she feel underused as vice
president of the united states and here
is her here's her inspiring answer
we're getting things done and we're
doing it together so you don't feel
misused or underused
no i don't i'm nervous very excited
about the work
that we have accomplished but i am also
absolutely absolutely clear-eyed that
there is a lot more to do and we're
gonna get it done um yeah man
and then she said she wanted to bring
down the cost of living this worked out
well for her for her boss joe biden
you'll remember last year suggested he
was going to get down the cost of living
and since then the price of a
thanksgiving dinner has exploded about
20 percent here is kamal harris
the cost of groceries has gone up the
cost of gas has gone up
and it as this is all happening in the
context of two years of a pandemic it's
one of the highest priorities actually
for the president and for me and so
we're dealing with this issue in a
number of ways short term one of the
issues is the supply chain we're seeing
a bottleneck and we need to relieve that
bottleneck so we brought together
everyone from the teamsters to target to
say hey let's all bring everyone
together from the truckers to the folks
who are moving product and let's open up
some of our major ports for
work 24 hours a day seven days a week
okay so this is not going down for for
camellias it's not going well
and and the democrats are looking
forward to 2024 and the other person
they keep trotting out there is pete
booty judge good luck with that like
really the american people are
definitely going to embrace the guy who
went missing on the job for two months
because he was on paternity leave
despite the fact that again paternity
leave was originally designed so you can
help care for a person who just
experienced physical trauma namely your
wife
people who judge took a two-month
paternity leave in the middle of a
supply chain crisis and no one noticed
and then he came back and bragged about
how he was a wonderful person for having
taken two months of paternity leave on
the public dime
so yeah good luck really good luck the
the intersectional firefight between the
lgbt wing of the democratic party and
the
and the people of color wing of the
democratic party is going to be a wonder
to watch
but says politico there is one person
one person who's being forgotten in all
of this mathematical calculation about
who ought to be the 2024 democratic
nominee we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about the fact
that you need a great pair of wireless
earbuds right you just use your earbuds
all the time
whether you are running on a treadmill
or whether you're just walking around
the city listening to music or whether
you're on a phone call you need a great
pair of wireless earbuds but those other
wireless earbuds they're really really
expensive not so with raycons raycons
are great with seamless bluetooth
pairing a comfortable noise isolating
fit you can start listening right away
and keep listening for hours the audio
quality is amazing comparable to what
you get from other premium brands except
raycon start at about half the price the
new everyday earbuds come with three new
sound profiles to make sure everything
you're listening to sounds its best with
just the right amount of bass you got
pure mode for podcast listening balanced
mode for rock they've got bass mode for
hip hop
raycon's offer eight hours of playtime a
32 hour battery life there's also a
built-in mic you can take calls on your
earbuds at the press of a button they're
convenient and they have great battery
life and they're not gonna cost you an
arm and a leg go to buy raycon dot com
slash bend today to unlock exclusive
deals up to 20 off your recon order
hurry the software is available for a
limited time only you don't want to miss
it that's by raycon dot com slash ben
it'll mock up to 20 off your raycons buy
r-a-y-c-o-n.com
ben alrighty so
here is politico speculating about what
ought to happen come 2024 quote amid the
glut of speculation about whether kamala
harris or p booty judge is joe biden's
political heir another important
succession story in democratic circles
has gone almost entirely undiscussed who
will inherit bernie sanders ideological
mantle during the past two presidential
cycles the vermont independent mounted
captivating extremely well financed bids
he lost twice but he reshaped the
democratic party the size and contents
of biden's domestic agenda have been
directly affected by sanderism he has
compelled democrats to embrace
government's intervention rather than
hide their faith in it from public view
but sanders like biden is old no one in
his orbit imagines him mounting a third
run should biden call it quits something
to be clear the president and his team
have explicitly said he isn't doing
this is left a void in the party's left
wing and it is causing anxiety among
progressive operatives who believe
sanders great discovery was that in the
era of online politics a presidential
campaign was an effective tool to push
unapologetic liberalism and this is true
by the way for a huge number of members
of the government is that they are
basically instagram influencers they're
not in the business of drawing
compromise deals and trying to figure
out good policy they're instagram
influencers
they're out there to try and get the
clicks and try and get the likes and try
to get the attention on on their little
videos because many of them make a lot
of money after leaving office based on
the sort of
following that they have built while
they were in office i've said for a long
time i have a pretty easy job and my job
is to tell you what i think on a daily
basis and i can be as honest about it as
i want to be which is purely honest
about how i feel about all of these
issues politicians don't have that job
politicians have to sort of smooth the
the sharp edges politicians have to make
deals that may stray from principle in
order to get things done
and i think that's an important thing
right it's an important job but
politicians who masquerade as principled
people who are who are just about
principle they can do really well in the
principled space this is why bernie
sanders has great popularity despite
never having done anything of use his
entire life and being an old communist
leech on the public dollar
okay well the the the question on the
democratic side of the aisle is this if
you've got kamala harris and pete beauty
judge and they're running against each
other and neither one of them have these
sort of soft spoken he's a dead person
appeal that joe biden had in 2020 right
his appeal was he wasn't bernie his
appeal was he was kind of just a thing
who was there and not all that
threatening well peter judge is pretty
threatening that dude says crazy stuff
all the time
and when pete buda judge first declared
for the presidency he seemed like kind
of an interesting candidate specifically
because he wasn't spitting on people
from middle america then within five
minutes he started
treating himself like pastor pete and
explaining that everybody who believed
in the bible
in traditional ways was actually a
brutal gay hater and that if you
interpreted the bible properly you
should just be a
gay marriage socialist essentially
and that that was that was p booty
judge's new pitch
didn't go over grade
and then there was com it went over
great with that with the democratic base
didn't go over great with anybody else
he has no appeal with the with the black
population in the democratic party
kamala harris has no appeal with anybody
so that leaves a pretty wide opening
actually there's a wide op here's the
dirty secret there's a wide opening in
the so-called moderate
wing of the democratic party and there's
a huge opening on the progressive wing
of the democratic party and the question
is which one of those wings actually
pushes forward in the next primary cycle
so in the sanders wing
politico says ask veterans of sanders
worlds who they think could fill that
lane and you get a host of recognizable
but not necessarily national names the
most common our band of house
progressives like pramila jayapal from
washington or rocano or of california or
katie porter of california or members of
the squad
i think the next chapter is bernie 2.0
in color says chuck rocha a former union
organizer who served as sanders's senior
campaign advisor the next sanders as
rochester will follow the path laid out
by one of bernie's major influences
jesse jackson whose rainbow coalition
presidential campaigns in 1984 and 1988
fused worker rights and multiculturalism
into a potent political force jackson
had his missteps including one fairly
infamous town one and they linked to uh
the story that would be the one where he
called new york hymietown because jesse
jackson is a vicious anti-semite but the
democratic party also went into abject
panic at the prospect of him winning
rocha thinks the party's in a new place
now having seen obvious slippage with
white working-class and hispanic voters
he surmises that politicians like ruben
gallego of arizona or annette baragon of
california or austin council city member
greg kassar a self-about democratic
socialist are the cleric and clearest
embodiments of the jackson vision but um
yeah nobody's ever heard of these people
so then they say what about elizabeth
warren
well elizabeth warren is old she flamed
out her best shot was actually in 2016
when she didn't take the shot there is
one other name and politico floats it
still there is one lawmaker who rocha
and several others said did have the
ideological makeup and infrastructure
already in place and a sanders
connection to boot
representative alexandria ocasio-cortez
democrat of new york who turns 35 the
legal hdb president under the
constitution on october 13th 2024.
bernie's no different than when he was a
crazy white-haired congressman says
rocha what legitimized him was when he
could raise tens of millions of dollars
that made him real to every power broker
in america and no one beyond aoc has
been able to do that
so get ready for the aoc 2024
presidential run i don't think this is
fantasy i really don't because here's
the thing what is aoc's trajectory
she's a congresswoman from a heavily
blue district in new york
she's not going to win statewide office
in order to be a senator in new york you
have to at least pose as a
non-democratic socialist
hey you do chuck schumer has played this
sort of inside outside progressive game
for a very very long time kirsten
gillibrand when she first ran for the
senate in new york ran as a gun-toting
pro-second amendment quasi-pro-life
person and then she shifted to the left
aoc is the most obvious progressive in
america
and she's not just a progressive she's a
wild-eyed progressive she says crazy
crap on a regular basis
she drove amazon out of her city and she
she has a record that is just terrible
in her home state so her home district
may like her because again it is a very
very blue district but the rest of the
state there's upstate new york you got
to worry about
aoc is not going to be the governor of
new york she's not going to be a senator
from new york
she could theoretically
you know
run for mayor of new york but bill de
blasio just flamed out
trying the same routine that aoc would
push to eric adams so what is her
trajectory and the answer is if you're
aoc why the hell not run for president
really why not
the media already love you the media
already slavishly pretend that you're an
intelligent human being with something
interesting to say even though
you have fewer than 10 brain cells to
rub together
you're camera friendly obviously so why
wouldn't you run
and
how could why not consolidate the
democratic party around you after all
you've got that intersectional coalition
running for you you're a woman of color
who
solidifies that democratic party
progressive base and you're attacked a
lot by the right which means according
to democrats that you are inherently
good
which moderate is going to stand up to
that you think kamala harris defeats aoc
in a presidential primary
i have some fairly serious doubts about
that
it's going to be fascinating to watch as
this as this war goes on in the
democratic party and i'm here for it
they built her up and now they're gonna
have to own it
enjoy embrace the suck guys it's gonna
be really bad in 2024 for the democrats
already in just one second we'll get to
the democrats and build back better they
voted on that this morning
cramming through a progressive laden
garbage bill that is going to damage
half their congress people get to that
in one moment first
you know struggling to watch joe biden
push a sentence out of his face you know
that that's difficult it's probably even
more difficult trying to figure out what
in the hell he is saying if you don't
have a hearing aid that's why you need
to check out md hearing aid md hearing
aid is an fda registered rechargeable
hearing aid it costs a fraction of what
typical hearing aids cost the average
price of a hearing aid in america is
over twenty four hundred dollars a pair
but their volt plus model is just 299.99
each when you buy a pair md hearing aid
was founded by an ent surgeon who saw
how many of his patients needed hearing
aids but couldn't afford them he made it
his mission to develop a quality hearing
aid that anyone could afford their sleep
design fits so well no one will even
know when you're wearing it it's
rechargeable with battery life that
lasts up to 30 hours
and if you forget to take your hearing
aids off in the shower you don't have to
worry because the volt plus is water
resistant in up to three feet of water
you don't even need a prescription or a
doctor's appointment you buy it directly
from them with audiologists and licensed
steering specialists available seven
days a week so how do they make these
hearing aids so affordable since about
95 of people who need a hearing aid only
require a few settings md hearing aids
simplify the need for certain components
not needed by most people plus they cut
out the price hiking middleman md
hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45 day risk
free trial 100 money back guarantee so
you can buy with confidence veterans
love empty hearing aid russell j says
he's worked around f4 fighter jets for
many years in the navy he thought he'd
never hear again like does he put that
vote plus in he could actually hear the
leaves crackling under his feet it's
time to reclaim your life from hearing
loss go to mdhearingaid.com use promo
code shapiro to get their buy one get
one
299.99 each offer plus they're adding a
free extra charging case 100 value just
for listeners of the ben shapiro show
head on over to md hearing aid.com use
our promo code shapiro or you can even
call them at 1-833
that's 1-833-773-1146
alrighty so
meanwhile the democrats for some odd
reason think that it's a great idea in
the house to shove through buildback
better i do not understand the logic of
this it is absolutely illogical i
understand that nancy pelosi wants to
demonstrate that she has some control
over her caucus but here's the problem
this bill's going nowhere
so it's going to get to the senate and
manchin and cinema are not going to vote
for this thing they're not going to vote
for this thing because it's a disaster
area the cbo has already said that it
adds almost 400 billion dollars to the
deficit and that's using the crappy
democratic math that says that the bill
is only
like two trillion dollars it is not a
two trillion dollar bill it is a five
trillion dollar bill
and it's being pushed through by a
president with a 36 approval rating
according to the latest polls joe
biden's approval rating is now lower
than the approval rating for tow fungus
i mean no one likes this guy
i mean let's go brandon start it off as
a coded chant for how bad joe biden is
and now people are beginning to be i
think embarrassed of saying let's go
brandon on the off chance that somebody
might think they actually are rooting
for biden
like there there is joe biden has lower
approval ratings than trump okay so for
all the talk about how unpopular and
terrible trump was joe biden is making
donald trump look like george washington
in terms of approval rating
and there's a reason for that it's
because he's not even with it anymore
here is joe biden he was signing his uh
infrastructure bill or another bill and
uh i don't know which bill it was
frankly because he forgot the name of
the bill so i have no idea what the hell
billy's signing right here
um what was that joe didn't repeat that
because um that that wasn't in english
once more
i just hope that he's not
you know i hope that he's not signing
somebody else's name to that bill
maybe i do maybe like a pocket video if
he accidentally signs somebody else's
name to the bill if he signs corn pop's
name to the bill
okay so this guy's no longer with us
and um and yet democrats rammed this
thing through anyway
they did
so what exactly is in this monstrosity
of a bill
well first of all it creates the highest
personal income tax rate in the
developed world
it creates the highest capital gains tax
rate since the 1970s
it creates a situation in which eight
states pay a combined federal state tax
rate of over 60 percent it creates 87
000 new irs auditors and agents which is
fun do you love the irs because this
place they just dedicated 80 billion
dollars
to increasing the size and scope of the
irs sounds like fun
you looking forward to it yeah it's
gonna be great
50 increase in small business audits
1.2 more annual
million more annual irs audits about
half hitting households making less than
75 000 a year is according to americans
for tax reform
there's an eight billion dollar home
heating tax
there's a 1.6 billion dollar special tax
handout for media companies which is by
the way a clear first amendment
violation the federal government is not
supposed to be in the business of
deciding which companies qualify as
local media companies for purpose of
giving them a subsidy that is a clear
violation of the first amendment to the
united states constitution because once
the government is subsidizing
particular outlets and calling the media
outlet so it can give them money and not
others that is rife for ideological
discrimination
it also does hike taxes on the middle
class
so the most hilarious thing about this
bill is that after joe biden claimed
that it would increase the taxes on the
millionaires and the billionaires and
that it would not increase taxes on the
middle class it actually gave a tax
break to millionaires and billionaires
in the blue states because it increases
the salt tax deduction okay so state and
local tax deductions the way that it
worked under trump is that he got rid of
those so the rule was before trump that
if you lived in california and you paid
a 13 state income tax you could take
that tax off the top of your income and
then on the lower line income you would
pay your federal tax trump came in he
passed the tax cuts the tax the tax cuts
got rid of that provision so now
whatever your top line income was it was
a million dollars now you're paying 13
for the california tax and then you're
also paying 37 for the federal tax
for biden it was you paid the 13
which took your number down to 870 000
and then you paid the federal tax on the
870 000 that's what biden is trying to
do so he's basically giving a tax break
to all of his friends in blue states
and and the white house knows this by
the way all right here's jin saki
admitting
is he comfortable where the current
provisions stand for these state and
local tax deductions given it would be a
pretty significant tax break for the
wealthy
well let me start by first
obviously wasn't what he proposed in his
initial package as you know but uh just
to come back to that um the president uh
also though it's been conveyed to him by
leaders in the house and senate that
this needs to be included in order for
this legislation to move forward and he
certainly understands that i mean it's
unreal it's unreal so he promised no
raising taxes on people who are middle
class and yes raising taxes on the rich
according to tim carney most
millionaires would receive a tax cut
from the democrats build back better
bill many middle class taxpayers would
see a tax increase
phil klein at national review spells it
out setting a tax policy center study
which concludes roughly 20 to 30 percent
of middle income households would pay
more in taxes in
a plus according to the center center
for a responsible federal budget a
household making a million bucks per
year will receive 10 times as much salt
from salt cap relief as a middle-class
family will receive from the child tax
credit expansion
so i guess that now aoc the 2024
presidential candidate is going to have
to wear a dress to the democratic party
caucus saying
tax the rich
or maybe her dress should just say
because she did i voted for a bill that
raised taxes on the middle class and
also gave a tax cut to the rich welcome
to the oligarchy alexandra ocasio-cortez
here was bernie sanders saying this is
bad policy
i think it's bad politics it's bad
policy uh the democrats correctly have
campaigned on the understanding that
amidst massive income and wealth
inequality we've got to demand that the
wealthy start paying their fair share of
taxes not giving them more tax breaks
the bottom line is we have to help the
middle class not the one percent
okay so
yeah this thing is doa in the senate so
what was the point of any of this what's
the point of it by the way the cbo again
reported that this would raise the
deficit by 367 billion dollars and then
they said well maybe maybe the irs will
claw back a bunch of money from people
so maybe it'll be like 160 billion
something like that okay here's the
reality it's going to be trillions of
dollars in deficits because the actual
cost of this bill is not 1.85 trillion
dollars the actual cost of this bill is
4.6 trillion dollars according to the
wall street journal the penn wharton
budget model estimates the house bill
would cost nearly 4.6 trillion dollars
over 10 years if temporary provisions
are made permanent as most will be
the committee for a responsible federal
budget pegs that cost at 4.9 trillion
dollars if temporary tax credits and
programs were made permanent through
2031 this would add not 367 billion
dollars not 120 billion dollars 1.5
trillion dollars to deficits over the
next five years without additional tax
offsets
okay so what exactly is in this budget
so they've enhanced child allowances
thirty six hundred dollars for children
under age six three thousand dollars up
to age seventeen this is the bill's most
expensive provision at about 130 billion
a year that's why democrats limit it to
one year does anyone think there's going
to be one year democrats are going to
try and leverage this into law forever
and many republicans will go along with
it the earned income tax credit
expansion triples the maximum eitc value
for childless adults but only for one
year
they say it'll only cost 15 billion
dollars but um if you extend it over a
decade which is what they want to do
it's 135 billion dollars
and by the way you can qualify based on
your previous year's earnings you don't
actually have to work to get this
particular tax credit
the new child care entitlement
households making up to 250 percent of
their state's median income would
qualify for child care vouchers their
payments would be capped at seven
percent of income less for lower earners
the bill appropriates 100 billion
dollars through 2024 to states and such
sums as may be necessary from 2025 to
2027.
and as you know the spending is going to
increase here's the thing the price of
daycare is going to go up not down the
reason it's going to go up not down is
because the same bill that subsidizes
daycare for all of these folks also
regulates who is allowed to receive
money as a daycare provider
it creates all sorts of new restrictions
on who gets to be a daycare provider so
it actually limits it increases the
demand and limits the supply which leads
to wait for it inflation
their universal pre-k bill appropriate
appropriates about 18 billion dollars to
states for universal pre-k through 2024
and then quote unquote such sums as may
be necessary through 2027.
the pre-k and child care entitlements
according to the wall street journal
are estimated to cost only 380 billion
dollars because they phase in gradually
and expire after six years but they're
not gonna expire in 2027 once people get
hooked the government just keeps doing
it which means they cost 800 billion
dollars if made permanent
so all of this is just a joke okay that
everybody and it's not going anywhere in
the senate and nancy pelosi by the way
speaks about what's in this bill
okay she says that um it'll yeah sure by
the way it allows taxpayer funding for
abortion
joe manchin said that that was a red
line he said he is not voting for a bill
that allows taxpayer funding for
abortion they stuck it in there anyway
nancy pelosi knows full well the entire
democratic party caucus in the house
knows full well this is going nowhere in
the senate so all she just did is make
all of her moderate members walk the
plank she's an idiot i'm sorry she's not
that great at this
there's been all this talk about what a
master negotiator nancy pelosi is i'm
wondering under what world that is true
under what blue moon is that true and
nancy pelosi is great at this all she
did is create a raft
of ads for republican candidates against
democratic candidates in purple
districts that's all she did
like pramila jayapal is happy today
she's not going to be happy when joe
manchin and kristen cinema kill the bill
but it's it is amazing here's nancy
pelosi admitting it allows tax fair
taxpayer funding for abortion
amendment are still not in the
reconciliation bill but weeks ago
chairman jeffrey said that anything is
on the table is that still the position
it's not in the bill it's not in the
bill thank you for your question it's
not in the bill
the it's
thank you for your question the hyberman
stand the bill right which means it's
doa
and then this crazy lady she says um
spending on climate change so there's a
ton of spending on climate change here
which is just a waste of money because
most of the spending on climate change
as all as far as i'm aware is not
directed towards say building new sea
walls
or shoring up infrastructure it is all
geared toward green energy bloon goggles
for political allies it's all solyndra
writ large here's nancy pelosi though i
love you gotta love the religious
principles of hardcore democrats like
nancy pelosi such a wonderful catholic
nancy pelosi that she believes that
abortion is a positive good but spending
on climate change is a religious issue
for me it's a religious thing i believe
this is god's creation and we have moral
obligation to be good stewards but if
you don't share that view you must share
the view that we have an obligation out
to future generations so we're very
excited
about what is in there and it is paid
for okay the kind of blasphemy that she
speaks from the podium you almost expect
the sky to open up and
the thunderbolt just come down
you have to believe we are stewards of
god's creation so we're going to spend
unbelievable amounts of money
to
pay off all my political allies why
gelato also that babies are fine
god doesn't care about the dead babies
good luck with this so um
congratulations to the democrats
i guess
for passing a bill that will go nowhere
in the senate and completely screws all
of the moderates in the democratic like
i don't even know how they how they
convinced the moderates to vote for this
thing how do you convince that josh
godheimer is the world this is a good
idea
i guess they just don't want to take
crap from the democratic primary but
they they don't want to take crap from
the democratic party they're afraid they
won't be able to get a job with their
friends after they're out of congress
but they're all gonna be out of congress
the republicans right now are running
eight to ten points ahead on the generic
ballot that is the biggest lead in the
history of the polling
republicans are set to pick up 50 60
seats in the house and nancy pelosi is
like what if i shove through this piece
of crap bill
that's filled with just garbage that no
one's gonna vote for in the senate
that'll be great
meanwhile i got joe biden adult joe
biden saying that bill back better is
going to lower the deficit he tweeted
out yesterday
my bloodbath better act is gonna reduce
the deficit by more than 100 billion
over 10 years
then he fell asleep and they woke him up
again and he continued it's going to
lower cost create jobs and
rebuilds our economy
let's get
this done
um it's not gonna reduce the deficit cbo
says it's not gonna reduce the deficit
you're lying about the cost of the bill
okay so kevin mccarthy decided to try
and hold this thing up he spoke for
eight hours and 37 minutes now um just
gonna put it out there any politician
speaking for eight hours and 37 minutes
is basically dante's seventh circle of
hell but here is kevin mccarthy ripping
into the bill
as appropriate the bill is a piece of
crap it's it's garbage
mr speaker we are minutes away from
voting on a
five trillion dollar
two thousand more than two thousand page
bill
some of its effects will be quickly felt
others not for a few years
but i guarantee you that no matter the
time frame
all the new washington spending in this
bill
is only the beginning of disaster
okay well that is true and if you don't
believe kevin mccarthy why don't you
believe the biden administration which
continues to maintain that its policies
are wonderful even as they have
precisely the effect they were intended
to have crushing americans yesterday
gensake defended cancelling the keystone
xl pipeline despite the fact that oil
prices are spiking
i think the problem with that argument
is that the keystone pipeline uh isn't
even really functioning i mean it was
only partially built it is even really
functioning so suggesting that uh
changing that would lower the price of
gas i don't know that that makes
substantive sense but the market looks
out and they look at where it will be in
the future and cancel the keystone
pipeline not allowing other pipelines to
go forward or challenging other
pipelines might reduce or cause some
concern in the world we look at every
pipeline on an individual basis the
president made the decision when only
about i think eight percent of the
pipeline had been built not to move
forward as we looked at the
environmental impacts and weighed them
with the economic impacts um and the
decision was certainly made uh no you
did you did not look at any of those
factors you just knew that the left wing
was fighting mad over keystone xlc
canceled it and then the gas prices have
risen because you have taken an anti-oil
and gas position in the middle of a gas
price bike because you guys are idiots
okay in just one second we'll talk about
the democratic party continuing to
double down on the most radical policy
imagine like are they just delusional i
don't understand what they're doing like
just again from a political perspective
it is going to go down in history as one
of the great acts of political
malpractice of all time that joe biden
entered office after a highly unpopular
one-term president and proceeded to do
everything he said he would not do
embracing the positions of the person he
defeated in the primary it's insane
it's legitimately insane you have to
wonder whether this geriatric patient
is even in control of his own brain at
this point to make that kind of
politically unpalatable move it's so
wild i've never seen anything remotely
like it we'll get some more of this in
just one second first
we're talking about the price of gas
right now yeah
have you seen it like that sticker shock
is pretty wild i'm thrilled to introduce
an incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code shapiro get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first philip
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using it get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your very first tank of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back there is no cash
the cash back gets added directly to
your account you can cash out any time
to your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands just
download that free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your very first
tank of gas that is promo code shapiro
and again that's up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on the first tank and
then beyond that up to 25 cents per
gallon on every single
gallon of gas like for the rest of time
that's a pretty great deal for just
downloading the app head on over to get
upside right now and download that app
at the app store alrighty
we'll get to more on all of this in just
one second first history is being made
right here at the daily wire with your
help we were the first company in
america to file suit against the biden
administration for their
unconstitutional vacs mandate we are
pleased to see the byte administration
suspended their implementation and
enforcement this week they are
continuing by the way to tell people
that they ought to
continue enforcement of this in lieu of
regulation don't do it if you're a
company stop it don't make their job
easy but
well what we've done so far is huge it's
not gonna stop yet okay the fact is this
is gonna end up at the supreme court
there are a lot of businesses who are
enforcing mandates our victory doesn't
mean anything unless those businesses do
the right thing and stop this nonsense
right now i understand you guys are
under pressure from the federal
government now you're not so
stop it if you're an employee your
company cannot force you to take a
vaccine you do not want or should not
force you to take a vaccine you do not
want don't let them hide behind the
vaccine mandate unless we lose nobody
should have to comply and we're not
going to lose we're going to win this
case it has now been consolidated at the
sixth circuit court of appeals we are
the lead plaintiffs in that case so far
sign our petition against joe biden's
vaccine mandate over at dailywire.com do
not comply send a message to the bite
administration that americans don't just
do whatever you tell them to do over six
hundred thousand people have already
signed the petition the more signatures
we get the louder the message that's why
we are aiming to get to one million
signatures so head on over to
dailywire.com do not comply and sign the
petition today also big announcement
this sunday i'm joined by my favorite
governor because he's my governor
florida governor ron desantis who's
taken a firm stance against the biden
administration's unconstitutional vax
mandates just like we have here at the
daily wire we sat down to make sense of
it all it is truly worth a listen we get
to everything from rhonda sansa's
handling of covid to why florida is
drawing people down here to his
philosophy of government in general go
check it out this sunday dailywire.com
or on my youtube channel ben shapiro is
a pleasure to sit down with the governor
i think you're really going to enjoy it
daily wire members get access to special
bonus content from sunday special
episodes so don't miss out join at
dailywire.com subscribe get 25 off with
code do not comply you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile again i don't know
what is driving so many thinkers on the
democratic side of the aisle these days
but it's certainly not reality there's a
piece from christina wyman
who is author of the forthcoming novel
jawbreaker she writes for nbc news she
has a piece today titled schools face
parents who want to ban critical race
theory and don't get how teaching works
an educator's top goal is to teach
students to think parents who dictate
curricula with their personal opinions
ideologies and biases hinder that goal
did you know the teachers have no none
they have no personal opinions
ideologies or biases teachers none they
are just perfect advocates of
socratic truth
or alternatively they want to
indoctrinate your kids and they don't
want you to know what they're doing
christina wyman says parents and
politicians across the country are
interfering with the curricula that
public schools use to teach students
state legislatures are passing laws to
keep critical race theory out of schools
literary classics like toni morrison's
the bluest eye are banned for sexual
content school libraries are coming
under attack for containing books about
gender there are even parents who are
trying to shield students from learning
about mental health and suicide as
though helping children build emotional
fortitude is a bad thing
while the political climate and national
involvement in school districts gave the
phenomenon a broader platform and have
more serious ramifications this behavior
is nothing new
parents have always tried to interfere
with curricula as i observed when
teaching middle school in the mid-2000s
even then there was no shortage of
parental input about the content of my
instruction from books to test questions
part of the problem is that parents
think they have the right to control
teaching and learning because their
children are the ones being educated but
it actually gasp doesn't work that way
it's sort of like entering a surgical
unit thinking you can interfere with an
operation simply because the patient is
your child oh
my god okay so let's begin with the
false analogy between being a surgeon
and being a middle school teacher i'm
sorry did you go to like eight years of
stem schooling in order to determine how
to operate on a kidney or do you just go
to a crappy ed school where they taught
you a bunch of social justice nonsense
and now you think that you're qualified
to teach children despite never having
dealt with actual real-life children
yourself very often
like
who makes the analogy between a surgeon
like a heart surgeon
and a person whose main job is to read a
curriculum designed by other people and
then infuse it with their own biases
that's ridiculous on his face second of
all
she says you know parents are are
misinformed if they think that they can
control their kids education the way
that they can control medical care wait
hold up parents do control their kids
medical care you idiot
we do this all the time
it is our job to decide whether our
children need surgery for example
now once i delegate that surgery to a
surgeon i shouldn't be bursting into the
room and trying to fix it but one of the
ways i pick the surgeon is by asking the
surgeon ahead of time what exactly
they're going to be doing i know this
because i've had to have watch my kid
have surgery it's no fun
this this bizarre idea that she's
promoting that when you hand your kid
over to the state the state is now the
expert on how to educate your kid is
crazy towns
the analogy is proper in terms of
parental action i get to decide whether
my kid has surgery i get to decide
whether my kid needs medical treatment
and i get to decide which doctor does it
but with the public schools i don't get
to decide any of that you forced my kid
to go to a public school if i can't
afford to go to a private school which
is why vouchers should be a thing so i
can choose where to put my kids
of course parents should have control
over education especially when you're
talking about subjects like english or
history
yes if a parent burst into a classroom
and said you're teaching calculus wrong
and then suggested
that we break out the abacuses that
would be silly
but that's not what we're talking about
here we're talking about the values that
are taught to your kids and so you have
now democratic thinkers saying no no
teaching english and history and social
science is exactly like teaching math
it's just incredibly stupid please do
this please
she talks about what an expert she is
when i first pursued teaching nearly two
decades ago i was struck by the list of
requirements i had to fulfill for the
state of new jersey to determine i was
qualified several years of focused
college instruction followed by intense
mentorship state level exams and more
exams i went to grad school i got a phd
in curriculum instruction and teacher
education well what do you frickin do
and by the way those state educational
standards have made new jersey the crown
jewel particularly inner city new jersey
the crown jewel of the world's
educational systems
so yeah hand it over to uh to the
experts and shut up i hope democrats run
on this i really hope they do and they
keep doubling down they're just doubling
down it's absolutely unbelievable
meanwhile the biden administration
continues to double down so we've
discussed the case of saul omarova
over the past couple of weeks this is
the person that the democrats want to be
comptroller of the banks essentially run
the banking industry in the united
states
she has said in the past that she wishes
to abolish all private holdings of of
savings accounts and checking accounts
that should all be done through the
federal reserve so then the fed can
determine who gets a loan and who does
not
she said in the past she wants to
bankrupt the oil and gas industry
yesterday she said she doesn't like
bitcoin yeah no bleep you don't like
bitcoin there's a shock you mean a
person who's in favor of centralized
government control over every aspect of
the economy doesn't like bitcoin which
is the alternative to centralized
government control of the economy color
me shocked here's salumarova the biden
administration's communist
nominee
for running in the banks by the way when
i say communist nominee i mean she
earned the lenin prize at the university
of moscow and will not reveal her phd
thesis before being nominated to this
position
do you believe that a government-issued
representation of currency of value
is superior
to private
commerce
i believe that we do have
government issued money right now in
this country and it's working great and
i worry about
allowing
private innovation
to undermine a lot of important public
policies
okay so um bitcoin is bad bitcoin is
super bad because it undermines public
policies it undermines the government's
ability to control all aspects of the
currency
it is not
bitcoin is a great alternative to the
government inflating the currency doing
whatever it wants with your dollar doing
whatever it wants with your savings
her deep desire to nationalize nearly
everything should scare the hell out of
everyone
now the left is trying to pretend that
this is not true
right the left is trying to pretend that
she is actually anti-communist that she
has some sort of free market here which
is amazing since like two years ago she
tweeted out that there was no gender pay
gap
in the soviet union
right things were wonderful in the
soviet union
she she says that she chose in her phd
program to study american democratic
theory and uh she was on exchange at the
university of wisconsin when the soviet
union collapsed she simply stayed
okay but um
this is this is an absurdity so her her
academic writing about the banking
industry
was all about centralizing all power
okay so
in her book the people's ledger how to
democratize money and finance the
economy a 71-page academic study on how
to separate big banks lending features
from their role as safekeepers of
americans at savings she wanted the
federal reserve to replace bank deposits
there's a reason she's being defended by
elizabeth warren
okay so john kennedy from louisiana he
uh he went after her in pretty colorful
fashion this of course
made many people very angry you're not
allowed to mention communism or marxism
ever ever because people might notice
in 2019 you joined the facebook group a
marxist facebook group
to discuss socialist and anti-capitalist
views
now that's what i see from your record
and you have the right to believe every
one of these things you do
this is america
but i don't mean any disrespect i i
don't know whether to call you professor
or comrade
how dare he
how dare he now she says now
that she has a unique appreciation for
our dynamic and diverse markets
but all of the things that you said
about our dynamic and diverse markets
are critical of those dynamic and
diverse markets so far as i'm aware
she said that her articles are designed
to expand the boundaries of academic
debate oh that's what it was she was
just raising issues
just raising issues okay so elizabeth
warren of course says it's a red scare
it's a it's it's how dare he it's a red
scare says elizabeth warren who herself
has embodied a lot of sort of marxist
ideals in her own campaigning
professor omarova i know that the giant
banks object to your willingness to
enforce the law to keep our system safe
and that you may cut into big bank
profits so they and their republican
buddies
have declared war on you the attacks on
your nomination have been vicious and
personal we've just seen them sexism
racism pages straight out of joe
mccarthy's 1950s red scare tactics it is
all there on full display
welcome to washington in 2021 by the way
the name of her actual thesis was quote
karl marx's economic analysis and the
theory of revolution in the capital
so
yeah i mean it seems like there should
be some open questions sure brown did
the same thing this is the senator from
ohio trying to defend omarova
we know that a shadowy political group
founded five seasons funded funded by
former trump staff has been fomenting
these personal attacks and pushing
radical right new right-wing news sites
to spread misinformation these
inflammatory insinuations continue to
stoke the unhinged rhetoric that is
poison or politics now now we know what
happens when trumpism meets mccarthyism
it's a cruelty no person should
experience it's so tiresome i'm sorry
this is so tiresome how about we find
out what she actually thinks and wonder
whether somebody with marxist leanings
ought to control the banking industry in
the united states
but really democrats keep apparently
they just think that if they keep
shouting trump over and over and over
and like beetlejuice he will appear and
then win elections for them this seems
to be their opinion of the situation it
really is quite amazing
meanwhile speaking of people who
continue to kowtow to the chinese
gensake yesterday was asked why joe
biden won't raise a covet investigation
with china joe biden has been very
hands-off with regard to the human
rights crisis that china has been
purveying in hong kong the threats
against taiwan joe biden has been
relatively
relatively sanguine about all of this
and of course he neither he nor john
kerry brought up the covenant
investigations with china which
unleashed a virus from wuhan on the
world which has killed some four million
people here's shinsaki trying to defend
it
did he ask president xi
to cooperate specifically with this u.s
intel agency-led investigation into the
origins of kovic peter it's clear that
that's what we want that's what we've
been pressing on i don't have any more
to who to read out for you from the
meeting you're saying that it's clear is
it clear to somebody who has a
zoom meeting with the president that
that's what he means if that's not what
he says
i think the president has spoken
publicly on this a number of times our
national security officials have
conveyed very clearly i don't think it's
a secret that's what we want that's what
we've been pressing before okay but yes
biden didn't say it to ji because he's
afraid of saying such things to ji
meanwhile joe biden was asked about a
diplomatic boycott of the beijing
olympics which are coming up in just a
couple of years here
and there already been some talk that
the administration was going to do it
and biden seems to be a little bit
walking it back
so do you support a diplomatic boycott
of the beijing olympics
something we're considering
something working somebody should inform
him his administration already floated a
trial balloon about just doing it okay
meanwhile speaking of that wuhan virus
investigation now people are trying to
claim that it was at the wet market
according to a scientist who has poured
over public accounts of early cover 19
cases in china he reported on thursday
an influential who inquiry had most
likely gotten the early chronology of
the pandemic wrong the new analysis
suggests the first known patient
sickened with coronavirus was a vendor
in a large wuhan animal market not an
accountant who lived many miles from it
that report was published on thursday in
the prestigious journal science it will
revive though certainly not settle the
debate over whether the pandemic started
with a spillover from the wildlife sold
at the market a leak from
virology lab or some other way the
scientist michael warabe is a leading
expert in tracing the evolution of
viruses at university of arizona came
upon timeline discrepancies by combing
through what had already been made
public in medical journals as well as
video interviews in a chinese news
outlet with people believed to have the
first two documented infections oribe
argues the vendor's ties to the huanen
seafood wholesale market as well as a
new analysis of the earliest
hospitalized patients strongly suggest
that the pandemic began there but here's
the thing we're never going to find out
whether this is true because joe biden
really doesn't care all that much about
whether this is true joe biden has
consistently said that he wants to see
china as a strategic competitor not as
an enemy well here's the thing china
views us as an enemy
okay and they're wielding their power
over corporate institutions in order to
get what they want
and we we thought that by opening up
china we would be liberalizing china and
to a certain extent we did we
liberalized parts of their economy we
certainly did not liberalize their
political system and instead what they
have done is they have now hooked us on
the opium
of cheap markets
and cheap goods
that is what they've done
and they've taken our corporations and
turned them inside out now listen
i think these corporations are gutless i
think these corporations should stand up
i think they should not go along with
this but i also think that the federal
government at a certain point western
civilization at a certain point has to
tell the chinese that we are going to
cut them off economically at the knees
if they continue to pervade the kind of
political terrorism in which they are
currently engaged
but instead we've got corporations that
are that are just cow towing to them
it's unbelievable
according to axios the marriott hotel in
prague declined to host a conference of
activists and leaders from china's
weaker diaspora this month citing
political neutrality an email shared
with axios shows
the chinese government has condemned the
world weaker congress which has
attempted to rally global attention to
the genus the genocide in zhang china
the decision to reject the conference
reflects china's growing ability to
extend authoritarian control beyond its
borders by making clear to corporations
that crossing the party's red lines will
be bad for business
about 200 delegates from 25 countries
gathered in prague from november 12th to
14th to elect the organization's new
leadership and hold discussions with
politicians academics and civil society
representatives from around the world
the prague marriott hotel declined to
host the conference because they said
they were afraid of pissing off the
chinese basically
so it's not just them by the way
obviously we've seen the nba kowtow to
the chinese as well in his cancer is i
will say he's he's
what he's saying about china right now
is just great so enos cancer is the the
center for the boston celtics
they are playing the lakers tonight
and he is uh he's going to be wearing
sneakers
that show
xi jinping putting a crown on king james
he tweeted out money over morals for the
king sad and disgusting how these
athletes pretend they care about social
justice they really do shut up and
dribble when big boss china says so
says did you educate yourself about the
slave labor that made your shoes or is
that not part of your research
and he's going after lebron james and
naturally soap and deb
foolish reporter from the new york times
like why are conservatives so excited
about this well maybe it's because
lebron is one of the most famous people
on earth and he is backing chinese
tyranny over freedom maybe it's that
someone does like why aren't you so
angry at at
tillman frittata or frittata whoever the
hell the owner of the houston rockets is
because no one's ever heard of him i
don't even remember his name
lebron james however is one of the most
popular and powerful political and
cultural figures in america so yeah
that's why it's great that enis canter
is going after him
good for him
really good for him
also good for the wta so the women's
tennis association
is now calling on china to explain what
the hell just happened to peng schwein
the penguin is a chinese tennis player
she put up a post on social media
alleging that a high-ranking communist
party official had raped her
the post was immediately taken down and
she was disappeared and then a statement
was issued to the wta in her name that
was obviously written by the communist
party
clearly written by the communist party
her post was deleted within 30 minutes
of publication her weibo account which
has more than half a million followers
is still blocked from searchers on the
platform
earlier this week chinese state media
released an email purportedly from pang
walking back her allegations saying they
weren't true and claiming she is fine
it was clearly staged it clearly was not
true
and so this put the wta in a bit of a
bind do they alienate the chinese and
stand up for this tennis player or do
they simply kowtow to the chinese
government the way the nba has
and good for them the wta was like nope
we're not doing it
according to cnn the head of the women's
tennis association steve simon has said
he is willing to lose hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of business in
china if tennis player peng schwein is
not fully accounted for and her
allegations are not properly
investigated
simon said in an interview thursday with
cnn we're definitely willing to pull our
business and deal with all the
complications that come with it this is
certainly bigger than the business women
need to be respected and not censored
good for him seriously more of this
more of this simon said when you factor
in the commitment to prize money and the
commitments to the wta and you factor in
the stadium building real estate
elements it's over one billion dollar
commitment they've made to the wta
finals and the wta in shenzhen
but apparently they're willing to pull
out serena williams also put out a
statement i'm devastated and shocked to
hear about the news of my peer penguin i
hope she's safe and found as soon as
possible this must be investigated we
must not stay silent naomi osaka
also released a statement with hashtag
where is pengshui we'll see if any of
these people have the uh the stones to
separate off from nike
for continuing to do business this way
but at least they're speaking out now
honestly really
credit to serena williams even if she's
not gonna cut ties with nike her
speaking out against the chinese
government at the risk of pissing off
nike is a good thing lebron is is just a
pathetic specimen
a pathetic moral specimen who on on
behalf of his shoe dollars stands up for
the chinese government
so i'm glad to see more people standing
up to chinese predations it is deeply
necessary at this point alrighty we will
be back a little bit later with an
additional hour of content first you
can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin joe drew
shows every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you head on over to
dailywire.com at 7 pm eastern 6 pm
central tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin